ganz kurze info eben bevor das video
losgeht ich werde gleich die ganze zeit
aussehen wie eine tomate dass sie gar an
da ich irgendwie so ein blaues t shirt
an hatte und dementsprechend eine kamera
dachte mensch sie zu blau hier ich mach
mal rot dass nur kurz los mein name ist
luca meine lieben freunde wir schauen
uns heute peinliche und klitschko bringt
das ist das für ein gesicht die sieht
aus wie dieses ding von monster ag wir
schauen uns heute aber auf jeden fall
fremdschämen de videos an wie
beispielsweise ein junge ein mädchen zum
abschlussball einladen wollte und sie
vor tausend leuten gesagt hat oder die
hochzeits anträge schief gegangen sind
coesfeld und so was also es kann nicht
nur scheiße werden die sind in einem
restaurant
und
er fragt wie
[Musik]
junge hat sich einfach rosen gekauft
schick gemacht das ist ein super team
hat sich wahrscheinlich richtig
rausgeputzt und zum ersten mal achse
alaska dich o benutzt im bad und von
papa ein bisschen aftershave drauf und
steht damit den rose und dann tut mir
leid
geht mich im nächsten video geht es
quasi um die genau gleiche situation und
zwar fragt auch ein typ ein mädchen ob
sie ihn zum abschlussball begleiten will
und das ist ja so ein riesiges in
amerika die in deutschland haben
allerhöchstens mal sonnen
ja wir haben gar nichts außer abi ball
aber der ist ja nicht jedes jahr sondern
auch nur einmal und auch nur wenn
mannschaft sandra kann auf jeden fall
fragte im nächsten video wieder ein typ
ein mädel ob sie ihn zum abschlussball
begleiten will und sie sagt auch nein
das ganze allerdings nicht wie vorhin in
einem kleinen café sondern vor 2.000
leuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es werden krank abschluss gewesen wenn
sie jetzt danach sagen würde ein remis
hätte date bad
to cancel dead and what to be with you
tube home instead
sprachenlernen im nächsten video macht
einen mann seiner freundin einen
heiratsantrag und man macht ja
eigentlich vorher schon so diese ganzen
verlobungs kram sodass man halt weiß
okay man gibt sich das versprechen das
man auch heiraten mit dass man für den
rest ihm zusammen sein will aber war
dies anders und dann ist man sich
eigentlich auch zu 90 prozent sicher
dass die person niemand heiratet die
galopp mann oder frau oder keine ahnung
also hinter identifizieren will auch
einfach ja sagt
darum geht sie aber jetzt gerade ich
glaube sie hätte auch ja gesagt aber es
war einfach nicht möglich aber seht
einfach selbst
geht auf die knie
und den ring aus
wie schon der hochwertig zu
eine riesige welle
ich schwöre euch wenn das mein antrag
wären ich könnte mir nichts besseres
vorstellen
das wird mein leben 11 beschreiben und
das wäre ein antrag an die man sich
immer erinnern würde beim nächsten video
geht es um einen jungen der nicht bei
seiner hochzeit dafür wäre er noch
deutlich zu jung aber auf einer hochzeit
auf jeden fall einen ordentlichen korb
bekommen hat aber schaut selbst hier
leuchten kleiner junge im leben geht es
aber nicht und wenn man sich als erstes
auf den 8 das geht nämlich um ihnen hier
bieten sich hier die beiden mädels
tanzen und jetzt wagt er seinen schritt
er geht vor
und fragt ob sie mitglied tanzen will
aber
sie dreht sich die ganze zeit von ihm
weg
das ist so traurig
das tut mir im herzen weh
er wird auch die nächsten zehn jahre
denken dass alle mädels blöd sind aber
warum bin ich eigentlich so roth in der
kammer
das anders sind die schilder nadja im
nächsten video wird abermals ein kleiner
junge bekommt der junge geht zum edel
umarmt sie und sie schubst ihn einfach
weg
warum musst du denn auch so gemein sein
aber das video geht weiter der junge
geht wieder dorthin möchte sie einfach
nur umarmen und sie hat gar keinen bock
auf ihn er gibt aber nicht auf er geht
wieder hin sie schubst ihn auf den boden
ich will viel sport moderator gerade der
jeder einzelne situation von einem
spieler kommentiert gucke jetzt sie
nimmt an schwung schubst ihn ergibt
nicht auf und sie und all ihre kraft
zusammen schubst ihn wieder auf den
boden eine stunde später das eigentlich
schon belästigung da mal jemand
einschreiten kommt aber dass dann wieder
auch körperverletzungen also ich weiß
nicht wirklich beide glaube ich einfach
ein knast stecken ich würde allerdings
sagen dass wir genug von kleinen kindern
gesehen haben und uns jetzt mal wieder
auf heirats fels konzentrieren
das find ich mindestens genauso quatsch
[Applaus]
das ist aber safe gestellt
warum sollte man dann wegrennen
ich würde auch einfach den anstand
besitzen in so einer situation gerade
wenn leute zugucken dann einfach ja zu
sagen aber danach er zu sagen ich hab
das schon gesagt dass es für dich nicht
peinlich ist davor den ganzen leuten ich
würde gern noch mal drüber nachdenken
das ist ein wichtiger schritt lasst uns
das nicht überstürzen er macht ihr
antrag
bei einem spiel im stadion alle gucken
zu
und links seht ihr sogar eine kamera die
das ganze filmt und sie kann es gar
nicht glauben und gibt ihm eine
backpfeife
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob es auch so kalt den
rücken runter läuft aber es ist einfach
so quin hier sind ein paar leute auf dem
boot
fahren bisschen lang mit freunden
und er fragt sie ob sie ihn heiraten
will mit den schildern sie hat
weggeschlagen und er in den see gefallen
die können solche arschlöcher seinen
namen der band organisiert
vor so vielen leuten
und jetzt macht ab
er redet die anderen filme
[Applaus]
ich finde das so schlimm
ich habe noch nie einen antrag gesehen
noch nie hatte ich irgendwie dass das
glück zu sehen wie so eine person dann
irgendwie in den antrag macht oder so
aber ich glaub ich würde einfach
wirklich heulen und wenn die personen
dann nein sagen würde wenn sich der typ
seine mühe gibt ich hoffe ich wird der
personal herlaufen der einfach eine
respekt stelle geben polizei nrw bitte
verfolgt mich jetzt nicht der fall hier
ist so schlimm das ist einfach am times
square in new york beweisen leute
drumherum schreien diese typische
amerikaner alter und sie kommen gar
nicht klar das ist so schlicht ist
weg
also falls das gar nicht verstanden er
ist zwar mit seiner freundin zusammen
und die haben sich in diesem park
kennengelernt und deswegen trifft er
sich jetzt heute wieder in diesem park
mit seiner freundin hat einen ballon mit
dem herzen vorbereitet und hängt da
einen ringen dran machen wir allerdings
weiter mit diesem heiratsantrag
jetzt mich auf die knie gegangen und sie
hat den ballon losgelassen
[Musik]
es wird durch dieses absichtliche
schenken und verstecken hinterm busch
sehr sehr scripted
aber dadurch dass das schon so alt ist
kann ich mir auch vorstellen ist es
wirklich will ist hier macht ein typ
seiner freundin einen antrag
auf der bühne
dieser moment wo der ding raus wurde ich
doch als frau da geht der puls direkt
auf 180
jetzt schaut euch einfach an was
passiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alle warten darauf dass ja ja sagt uns
die leute einfach warum laufen die
frauen dann immer weg sagt doch einfach
ja und nachher dann nochmal nein oder so
hier macht jemand
einen antrag
beim baseballspiel
wo mein gott das ist der billigste mein
gott das maskottchen sagt dann auch alle
sollen eins sein wollen und sie kommen
gar nicht glauben gott ich mache die
fans gerade nach unten
[Musik]
da wird tut mir leid ich kann nicht tut
mir leid
habt ihr alle keinen anstand egal ob wir
nun allerdings auch schon zum letzten
heiratsantrag feld für heute und zwar
wieder etwas im stadion
man muss sich schon sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr sicher sein um vor
so vielen leuten öffentlichkeiten antrag
zu machen
[Applaus]
in spanien
kann ich selber auf jeden fall nein
gesagt aber wie in marokko in spanien
live streaming ads und erzähle ich das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden weil der liebe freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat er das gern einen
daumen hoch unter diesem video hört da
aber niemand kanal und klickt auf die
glocken weitere videos nicht verpassen
in welchen fällen und ihrem schlimmsten
die hochzeits fels die waren schon schon
krise aber ich finde dass mit den
kleinen kindern am schlimmsten die sind
doch für ihr leben lang nicht mehr
glücklich wenn du einmal so ein korb
bekommen hast